la histórica decisión de convertir a
Montana en el primer estado del país en
prohibir tiktok no cuenta con unanimidad
5 usuarios de la plataforma presentaron
una demanda ante un tribunal Federal
para bloquear la prohibición denuncian
que la ley viola la primera enmienda de
la Constitución a lo largo de nuestra
historia el gobierno ha utilizado
motivos de seguridad nacional para
justificar violaciones de nuestros
derechos de libertad de expresión es el
truco más viejo del libro para intentar
justificar la privación de la libertad
de expresión de los estadounidenses y
por eso es algo contra lo que tenemos
que luchar por otro lado parte de la
población sí apoya la decisión del
gobernador de Montana Greg Jean Forte
creo que suena como que algunos riesgos
muy graves con el uso y la información
que se está recogiendo de ella y después
de oír hablar de ello e Investigar un
poco más creo que estoy de acuerdo
el republicano afirma que se necesita
proteger datos privados de los usuarios
Estados Unidos sospecha la aplicación de
haber recopilado datos de millones de
estadounidenses para Beijing a partir
del primero de enero de 2024 Apple y
Google tendrán que dejar de ofrecer la
aplicación en su plataforma o
enfrentarse a una multa de $10,000 al
día en este estado de una población que
apenas supera el millón de habitantes
son muchos los que aseguran necesitar
tiktok para impulsar sus negocios en las
redes Más allá de las fronteras de monta